if conservatives looked at DOJ looked
like they looked at EPA or FDA they'd
see the same sorts of abuse and Fraud
and overzealous use of power and that's
what they need to do i am nick gillespie
with reason TV and today we're talking
with Kevin ring he's the director of
strategic initiatives and the families
against mandatory minimums or fam Kevin
thanks for talking about thank you
having this is a banner time for
criminal justice reform a lot of things
going on in the headlines especially the
Department of Justice has just released
over 6,000 criminals from the federal
prisons what's going on with that well
6,000 drug offenders have been released
because more than a year ago the US
Sentencing Commission which is not
connected to the Justice Department made
a decision to reduce the drug guidelines
by two levels that's how they calculate
the sentences right they decided drug
weight was driving the census too high
they moved them down and as a result
6,000 people 46,000 over the course of
the next 10 years will get relief when
conservatives especially they say Obama
is released yeah he's like he's going
with his big jailers keys and opening
doors it really isn't that it's not
Obama in fact the Justice Department
argued against most of this release they
wanted to put conditions on who could
get this retroactive relief among these
six thousand these are nonviolent drug
offenders yes almost wholly there's very
few violent prisoners in the federal
system those are mostly in state prisons
so these are people who have drug
offenses it may be the case that they
had a gun at some point or they have
some previous conviction it's not
they're not going around shooting people
up or anything absolutely not and a
third of them are going to be deported
that's right so you're talking about
4,000 people in a country of you know
300 million so this isn't some tidal
wave of folks this is a few each
community now Jeb Bush you know one of
the Republican presidential candidates
former governor of Florida he called
this the wrong approach but for the
right reasons or the right goals and he
specifically said look there's a lot of
people in Congress on the Republican
side who we're talking about this Obama
should have worked with them does that
make sense or is that a fair assessment
of the situation no I think this is all
hands on deck situation so the
president's doing what he can through
commie
tations Congress is taking up criminal
justice reform and the Commission this
is their job is to reevaluate sentence
lengths they did that they changed it
going forward and out of fairness they
said we also have to make this change
retroactively so these are the lowest
hanging fruit these are the safest
people we have so if this is a problem
you know it's hard to think they're
going to accept any other sort of reform
so where did the mandatory minimums come
from and why is the steam kind of coming
out from pushing those well we got
mandatory minimums mostly in the 80s and
90s where people want to get tough on
crime they want to lock everybody up
because we did have a higher crime in
the late 70s and they thought that was
the right response and so crime went
down and so if you looked at those two
tatah points if you said we put in
mandatory minimums crime went down you
would argue they have done well but the
state started going broke their
Corrections budgets were going out of
control so they started changing them
you had states like Michigan New York
Rhode Island repealing their mandatory
minimums investing that money though and
other things law enforcement things and
their crime rates continue to drop so
the feds have said we now have evidence
that we don't need to have these
policies and in there at a point where
they need to change it because we're
diverting so much money from FBI agents
prosecutors into holding nonviolent
offenders and even somebody like Rick
Perry the former Texas governor he
bragged last year at CPAC a conservative
meeting that he had closed the prison in
Texas yes what would you know this seems
to be a moment where people on the right
and the left libertarians and
progressives everybody is in for
criminal justice reform that's right and
in Texas what they'll tell you too is
the reason they were able to do what
they did was because they don't have the
mandatory minimums we have the federal
level and some others dates so when they
were able to do more in programming do
more sort of risk assessment and let
people out and use incentives they were
able to do that because they didn't have
mandatory sentences but Perry is a good
example of this growing trend you have a
right on crime group out there that's
full of you know old conservative
leaders you have the Koch brothers you
have probably also New York yeah and
then and then the traditional allies on
the left but it's it's been amazing to
watch and there is a consensus now that
at least with nonviolent offenders
motion drug cases we can do it better is
this also part of you know we just saw
oh hi
fail to pass pot legalization but
perhaps more stunning was that pot
legalization was up for a vote in Ohio
is the impulse towards mandatory
minimums starting to become undone as
the drug war seems to be winding down
yeah and I think a good good piece of
evidence for that is look at how crack
was treated now there are difference
between crack and heroin but they're too
serious drugs and crack was considered a
law enforcement problem we that's when
mandatory minimums really hit and now
we're talking about a heroin epidemic
and everyone's be doing this is public
safety or public health crisis that
reaction couldn't be more different than
what we did in the eighties in the 90s
and I think it's just a sign of progress
right well another side of that is a
poll that fam conducted recently that
talked about ending mandatory minimums
for nonviolent crime tell us about those
findings and why they're hardening for
you well we did a poll about five years
ago and it found that sixty percent
supported repeal mandatory minimums this
poll just five years later showed
seventy-seven percent and along the
lines of what you were just saying it's
across the board across the political
spectrum the biggest jump was among
Republicans and self-described
conservatives among that group of full
71 percent now support repealing
mandatory minimums that would have I
mean that would've been unheard of
twenty years ago and so across the board
people are changing their mind on this
they think there's other things they can
do and there's evidence to support that
and so now the biggest change I would
say also is law enforcement we've
recently had a new group come out law
enforcement to reduce crime
incarceration so the people with badges
are now saying we don't need we have the
wrong people in jail we need resources
to go after the bad guys but we've got
that we're wasting it on these I'm not
holding these though now this is not a
simply an academic or philosophical
discussion for you you are a convicted
felon I could tell us a little bit about
what the you know what you were
convicted for and what your experience
what kind of insight that gave you about
reforming criminal justice and
sentencing sure well I was convicted a
white-collar offense I was a lobbyist in
Washington DC and I was convicted of a
junior varsity form of bribery and so I
went to a federal prison camp there are
no white collar camps these are mostly
drug and gun offenders I served with for
a year and a half and I saw the people
who were serving mandatory minimum
sentences I wish everyone had
tunity maybe as visitors because they're
not who you think they are I mean these
are people who made mistakes made bad
judgments but it's not because they they
knew the law they knew there was a
chance of getting caught and just just
did a cost-benefit analysis they just
made stupid decisions and a lot of them
will tell you they needed to be punished
and held accountable to get on the right
track but they don't need 10 or 20 years
to figure that out and so you just see a
lot of waste because these people aren't
going to come out any better than when
they went in and there's things we could
do that would make them less likely to
recidivate which is in our interest
right so you would think what are some
of those things and is that part of our
those kinds of reforms really going
forward or are we talking about window
dressing well the bills in Congress talk
about that because they talk about doing
front end and back end so you'll reduce
sentences which is very important but
you'll use that savings to do things on
the back end like more drug treatment
also things that aren't necessarily
related to drugs but cognitive
behavioral therapy teaching people their
thought process that people have bad
decision-making run and bad impulse
control control ray exactly and and and
so these are some of these crimes are
almost honor crimes you know they're
just out of vengefulness their gang
related or they're just they're just
things that people can grow out of and
so that's why some people do age auto
crime so they want to do more
programming like that job training is
important and then the other thing is
when they get job skills that they can
come out with we got to make sure that
they're employable and so that's the
other thing is we got to work as a
country on letting people come back in
have jobs talk talk a bit about that
because Obama recently was talking about
we got to get the box off of application
saying have you ever been arrests and
have you ever been convicted and that
seems to be a good idea but it's also
true that that's happening voluntarily
at places like walmart and other places
is yeah more important that cultural
change the legal one or how do they work
to yeah I'm sure that the president can
sort of contribute to that cultural
change but it's happening and just
banning the box you know if I interview
you for your job I may not ask you in
your application but I see a 10-year gap
in your resume that's a problem and so
the question is more how am I going to
react to that gap then whether I asked
you the question and so we need people
to realize that just because you serve
time you're not disqualified from
sir and this is something over the past
30 40 years the I mean the United States
went from being Karg you ibly the land
of the free to the land of the
incarcerated if you know is that a
factor here that everybody now knows
people who have been in [ __ ] pretty much
I think that's right i mean the numbers
that pew f found one in 101 adults one
in 35 under some sort of control either
parole probation jail or prison that's a
staggering number and so we grew up in I
grew up in a time where no one knew
somebody who went to prison now my kids
don't know anyone who doesn't know
somebody who went to prison and I think
it's it's like other cultural changes
for instance gay rights where the more
people associate with people who have
had these experiences they change their
opinion of it families against mandatory
minimums it said fam org fa mmv what
what does victory in your cause look
like for fam it looks like rational
sentencing laws where judges have the
power to give long sentences to people
who need long punishments and to give
shorter sentences to shorter punishments
it's not revolutionary it's the idea
that we are individuals the mistakes we
make our individual mistakes and the
punishments we get for those mistakes
should be individualized so that's all
it is and and it's not anti punishment
it's not anti prison it's just the idea
that we should be treated as individuals
so it's kind of bringing you know a
bedrock value for conservatives no
one-size-fits-all that's true and
education it's true in you know in all
sorts of things including sentencing
yeah and if conservatives looked at DOJ
looked like they looked at EPA or FDA
they'd see the same sorts of abuse and
Fraud an overzealous use of power and
that's what they need to do and those
who are doing it like Mike Lee and Rand
Paul when they look at it they're saying
we're not getting the biggest bang for
the buck if we're supposed to get out of
Justice Department Public Safety we
could get more for less money so let's
do those things and so that's why I
think you're seeing conservatives come
around alright well we'll leave it there
we've been talking with Kevin ring he's
from families against mandatory minimum
thank you so much for talking thanks for
having me for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
you